ich will lehrerin werden was empfehlen
sie mir sie von lehrerin werden ja was
motiviert sie ihr habt so einen
grundsätzlichen haffs auf mein leben und
ich habe zu sehen mit der comedy also
die ganze zeit beklatscht werden kohle
verdienen die leute erinnern sich an
einen habe ich einfach keinen bock mehr
drauf dann ist lehrer definitiv der
falsche beruf weil bis auf kohle
verdienen ist das quasi genau das
gleiche
70 prozent der lehrer beschweren sich
darüber dass die sanitären einrichtungen
nicht gut sind dass die schule nicht
hygiene nicht genug ist wäre das
vielleicht ein ansatz dort geld
reinzustecken ja ich glaube wir brauchen
beides man kann das eine von dem andere
nicht ausschließen man könnte die schule
ja auch mit ipads einfach neue fliesen
ja alles was der schüler schreibt sieht
der lehrer vorne an der tafel
also kann man keine pins mehr penisse
mehr daran kritzeln ohne dass der lehrer
es merkt das sieht er dann auch vorher
schon
das nicht eine voodoo-puppe von jemandem
tut jetzt nicht der bauch welt von
jemandem wie beta also das ist nicht das
tut jetzt nicht ihnen im bauch weh
[Gelächter]
die füße stark wie ernst ist in ihrer
intention lehrerin zu werden
wahrscheinlich eher nicht so oder na ja
also das also so ernst wie sie einen
vollbart verfolgen sagen wenn sie mich
anschauen was es um eine form von
respekt die ich erwarten kann
ich denke wenn sie jetzt mit einer
joggingjacke vor die kinder treten sind
sie eher im bereich kumpel unterwegs
dann muss ich schreib doch mal ein
romantisches leben sehr gut wenn man
bedenkt wie gut einem so carnevals
gesänge im ohr bleiben dann wäre es ja
eigentlich eine gute idee sich so zb
genomische formeln mit carlos gesängen
zu merken oder warum nicht aber ich
mache es gerne mit rap oder mit zwingen
wenn sie mal die mimische formel rappen
die zweite beta
[Musik]
digitalisierung ja jetzt sind wir dabei
intellekt und emotion gemeinsam zum
klingen bringen
ich will nachher noch mit klasse
unterrichten wie muss man da auftreten
wie sagt man halo zu einer klasse
einfach sagen genau oder den schweige
fuchs das ist im grund ist schlosser das
funktioniert echt und ehrlich
[Applaus]
schon wieder eine verlorene generation
und damit zurück
[Musik]
für weitere videos klickt unten und
abonniert auch unseren channel alles im
kasten
ok wo geht's hier raus
scheiße